[Music]
right now
out of the flower beauty line i cannot
live without this
it's the day glow highlighting glaze and
it just comes in this really compact
palette
i just go right along
the top of the cheekbone like where the
cheekbone
is pronounced not in the contour line
and it's so foolproof that's what i love
about this product too
you do not have to be a master or an
artist
you just throw it on those little
highlighting things
areas brow bones i really like to do
this a little bit on my eyelids
then what i like to do is go along the
jawline
just ever so slightly and as my
famous line goes i lost my chin in 2019
it's because i lost my jawline too
anyway
look you can see it's like so blendable
it's really foolproof and that's what i
love about this
a funny thing i tend to forget about is
nose hairs now i have done one of those
machines that plucked
everything out and i felt like a naked
gazelle
i felt so sexy i was like oh my god nude
nostrils
everything and then i got horribly sick
and i was like maybe there is something
to those protective fibers
of nose hairs but when the nose hairs do
grow long
as you can see like powder
gets caught in them and it's not very
attractive i'm gonna actually go with
the word disgusting
so what i like to do is
take these kinds of scissors you can buy
them on
amazon or anywhere they're rounded so
you can actually get right in
the nostril and start trimming around it
and because they're rounded at
the end they won't cut you they're safe
to use in and around the nose
then also like a q-tip and just go
around the inside
and make it all nice and pretty it's
those funny little steps
that we tend to forget but when we go
out in the world
those little details make a big
difference
i'm growing my eyebrows back in
and i have the flower beauty brow fix
which is my favorite because i love a
spoolie
and then i'm uh doing the um
micro brow pencil to fill in
a little hole right here i love
the other side because it has this
beautiful little
brush and
you can just make this perfectly angled
quaffed eyebrow
gosh they're so much thicker like
already it's crazy now
this is what i love about this
just say you want to do something
totally different than a
sort of perfect arch brow
much more expressive too
how do you brow something i want to
share with you guys that i totally
learned last night i have always heard
about ice ice ice so i got this huge zit
thank you and then popped it
best ever and then i put ice on it
and this morning it's better although
it's bright red and hideous and like
scabbed over and not gonna be easy to
cover
it literally made all of that toxic
swelling that happens from when you're
pushing on it i mean this should have
lasted another
day but by tomorrow it's going to be
gone where
in reality i would have woke up there
probably would have been more infection
and then i would have like dealt with
that all day and then i'd still be like
kind of at square one
but tomorrow the scabs gonna come off
it's gonna be
flat it's gonna be discolored that
visine trick works too
but the visine on the redness it really
lightens it up
so ice and visine when you
get one of those wonderful awesome
you know ones